alright let's see if we could follow um
one of those games for a little while
longer know we have the allen counter
gambit something we're very unlikely to
see in the world championship that would
be cool but I don't know about that I
think night out right away is best and
then 83 doing III you're going to get
big trouble if you do that if you do III
and I'm not really up so familiar with
this opening and I really don't like
that gambit very tempted to just say you
know I take that pawn back I really just
want to play e6 right here hmm I don't
want to go in the gambit mode here I'm
not just see six e6 Bishop takes III
hmm i'm stuck can you tell I'm tongue
tied as well I don't know what to say
about this opening in this position take
out of six by push forward with e6 I
don't think that this is good I really
don't want to enter a gambit but might I
be having to just go in that direction
well I'm gonna chop just going to take
it and follow up with my light square
Bishop of course coming on g2 and well
I'd like to get in be four eventually
and maybe work against this pond I have
to be very careful because very soon we
could just have opposite sides castling
and my opponent could maybe be running
for some battery along this diagonal the
removal of a very important defender of
my eventual kingside castle position and
you know something like h5 h4 stuff
could not be well it could be happening
not to long off ok we go Bishop g4
pressure right night I need to get
developed ok preparing this I want to
keep that Bishop way yeah get out of
there bishop I don't want to allow the
light squared Bishop exchange nope ok
well if I take with my epon this guy
becomes past if I take with my bishop I
can't castle so quickly
because I'd be dropping the h3 pond
decisions I do have the bishop pair now
take with my bishop or pawn how about I
just take the bishop with my bishop and
then come back to g2 and then Castle
chop come back Castle and everything is
okay i don't know if i could say
everything's okay this is a time is
going to be a big factor that's why I'm
kind of questioning the decision to take
with my bishop here do I have the time
should I be able to should I be devoting
such time to that I'm gonna allow this
pawn to be passed I'm uh I don't have
time I'm viewing as a greater factor
than you know than anything here so let
me castle and well if this pond presses
forward I can't play Knight c3 because
of d2 and my bishop is crunched so just
want to avoid that and in the meantime
where is this Bishop going to go I could
be expanding on the queenside I could be
playing f4 in fact this is something I
want to do if h5 is played I think I
meet that with h4 and I really just want
to keep a grip over the g5 square h 5 is
played so I think I'll have an easier
time defending my king having a group of
four pawns here and this is something i
just did not even consider should this
be something i cringe at here night
putting pressure on this pond play Queen
up
yeah what's wrong with just clean up
there's nothing wrong with that there's
two good reasons for this one watch the
pond in to blockade that pond the queen
is a terrible blockade ER but she's
going to just gonna have to deal with it
for right now I'd like to just kick this
night away in fact my first thought was
just played b3 and it's usually best to
avoid situations where you're tying your
own pieces down to the defense of the
puns but keep in mind i just want to
alleviate this situation that my queen
is in by playing be4 kick that guy way
he's a bug and I'll have to be concerned
about nighy five moves but I think
that's met with F for two good reasons
for it just watch over e5 and let the
bishop see um so I think right now I do
this maintain my queen position maintain
the blockade let my bishop see and
follow up moves maybe be four maybe
Knight d2 and well actually where else
is my not going to go probably has to go
here night out our pawn to b4 those are
the only two modes i'm considering
I'm going to play this just you know I
may be there be a five although i'm not
so sure about that and now night here
daily spot i could go and well I guess
everything is falling into place here
you kind of have to go with these moves
there's not not a better way to really
reorganize my minor pieces so Bishop b2
coming up and then I'm in a spot to
contend or contest the only open file so
here we go I could kick this night away
with a b5 however I might first want to
play Knight B 3 so that after b5 the
night can make use of 85 it have to run
in Reverse I could also think about c5
and then night see for this would be a
nice improvement for this guy it does
however allow for a night to pivot on d5
and this move I believe can't be right
or can it because I could rip open the B
file now this is a hook b5 some file
will open up completely or well behalf
opener completely open so be five yes
let's go with it this is this is the
right thing to do my other thought was
play route to e1 but let's open stuff up
a six was something to just avoid keep
those keep those ponds back as far as
possible oh that must have been a mouse
lip I threw out a take back there that
had to be a mouse slip right there pawn
takes was probably meant there we go and
now the night I guess is running here
but I have the C file to be playing on
and I'm going to go with this rook right
here purposeful and maybe I still have
thoughts of bringing this R up to this
square so that's why I went with this
one to see one night c4 threatens Knight
b6
which is killer if night plays here I
could take this bishop or this pond but
my bishop would end up in a pin after
the night moves again these two guys
come right to life less than thirty four
black time issue big time issue um
what's the scoop here seeing some
sneakiness like Queen out here something
someday
time time time time time time is a big
issue here okay this is a problem on the
rook the night isn't a pin Queen here as
possible my that's my first stop yep I'm
on the night the night spin done c7
pressure on b7 no time for black in the
complications all right good game let's
back up when you flip the board and see
how things were from your perspective so
the ALB encounter gambit if you're
looking for more information on it it's
a esio code d0 883 keep in mind the e3
move you end up getting killed it's an
easy trap to fall into if you play III
challenging this guy there's Bishop
check that's why I'm playing a 3 to
watch over be4 and looking forward to
expanding how could black have played a
bit different I think it has to do with
this decision to take my night I think
things are pretty comfortable for me
after this exchange and you know he's
passed but I don't know your nights
going a bit of stray when he goes to a 5
I don't know if that's an inconvenience
I just blockade defend and I get this
move in with tempo eventually so I think
the turning point one of them at least
this is the one that's in my mind at
least is the decision again to take the
night after your bishops challenge may
be coming back here and then it's a bit
uncomfortable for me I can't castle
immediately that's where the uncomfort
is a you know coming from here so I
think right there don't take the night
and just come back to e6 that might have
been something my opponent was
considering but anyhow I'm thinking that
that was another one to be going with
keeping pressure on h3 the main point
there I think things tip in my favorite
I am up a pond and
as soon as I get developed where you
know i'm not seeing where the
compensation is and if you can't remove
the queen from this blockade square on
d3 then it's not really much going on
keep in mind what a six is really doing
it's helping white get in an open file
so you'll definitely want to steer clear
from doing a six but i think no matter
what's played on the black end here it's
still very difficult rooks are in good
spots but there's not really a fantastic
way to make a good improvement from here